the former Chancellor sported a casual
look
hardly the garb of an oil executive
Gerhard schröder was intending to give
his party a boost but the assembled
audience was more interested in the new
job he might get will he be joining a
Russian oil giant that's close to the
Kremlin I believe in what I'm doing for
economic and political reasons it's
unwise to isolate our biggest neighbor
Russia economically and politically
economic policies alia many have
criticized Schroeder's latest ambitions
but the SPD wants to demonstrate unity
and avoid controversy Schroders advice
to his party in Maidan vendee Laura and
whenever people write you off that's
your chance one fights best with ones
back to the wall that's my experience
zoe hidden thoughts minor foul it's
mostly Schroeder fans who turned out but
opinions were divided over his lucrative
involvement in Russia person's right to
earn money where they want win in Russia
or the US
I'd say he's helping the SPD campaign I
think it's not necessarily the job one
should have as a former German
Chancellor whether Gerhard schröder
winds up helping or harming his party's
chances remains to be seen but everyone
at the event understood clearly that the
SPD has to keep fighting till Election
Day on September 24th